Republicans are now staging ridiculous
hearings in New York City on violent
crime these are Republicans from the
House of Representatives and you might
say David wait a second House of
Representatives Washington D.C federal
government why are they holding these
hearings in New York City the reason
they are doing it
is because they are trying to run
interference for Donald Trump's
indictment and arrest by attacking Alvin
Bragg with the idea why is Bragg going
after Trump when Bragg has violence in
New York City to deal with now of course
you and I probably see that and say wait
a second prosecutors can do multiple
things at once one of the problems we
have in the United States which I've
pointed out is that there is too much
focus on Street crime rather than
corporate financial and white-collar
crime that doesn't mean we ignore
violent crime it means that we have a
system that at its systemic structural
level
focuses on one type of crime and not the
other and that leads to a
disproportionate focus on wealthy people
I'm sorry not unwealthy people but
rather on poor people we've talked about
this before low effort low hanging fruit
policing for example makes it much
easier to just go to a poor neighborhood
and you know harass people stop and
frisk Etc and not actually partake in
the other types of investigative work
that we should be seeing so Alvin Bragg
is doing nothing wrong but Republicans
want to make the case there's violence
in New York and Alvin Bragg is indicting
Trump for nonsense the other element to
this is that we have a red State murder
problem and a red City violent crime
problem but Republicans don't want you
to know that they want you to believe oh
it's liberal cities that are dangerous
and that's it so let's take this from
the top NBC news reports Trump allies
take fight to Bragg's backyard with
hearing on New York City crime the
Manhattan district attorney Prosecuting
Donald Trump highlights new police data
that shows murders and under other
violent crimes have actually fallen in
the borough since last year there's a
picture on the screen of Republican
Congressman Jim Jordan
uh because he is leading this uh these
series of hearings as absurd as they are
the argument that Republicans want to
make is Democrats are weak on crime as
it is uh blue cities have a crime
problem and Alvin Bragg epitomizes this
problem by going after Trump rather than
going after the violent crime well Eric
Adams the mayor of New York City was on
MSNBC this morning and he accurately and
rightly pointed out that not only is
this a political stunt but there is
actually a bigger problem with violent
crime in many republican cities here's
Eric Adams why let's bring in the mayor
of New York City Eric Adams by the way
what do you think of this field Hearing
in your city about crime I think is the
highest level of hypocrisy
we know that cities all across America
are dealing with the issues around
Public Safety particularly the criminal
justice system and right in the largest
city in Ohio I was reported today in one
of the tabloids of the murders of over
50 percent in the first quarter and so
while crime is going down homicides are
going down here Shooters are going down
here some of the major uh crimes you're
trending in the right direction our
subway system crime is going down so I
think coming here and highlighting uh
D.A Bragg it's just really a political
stunt now is Eric Adams correct yes he
is it is true that in New York City in
2022 there was a violent crime rate a
homicide rate of 5.2 per hundred
thousand people whereas in Columbus Ohio
there was a homicide rate of 15.4 per
100 000 people the homicide rate in 2022
was nearly three times higher in Ohio
than it was in New York City we've
talked about both violent and property
crime rates being higher in Oklahoma
City a red City in a red State then in
New York City and New York State and
then there is also something as I
mentioned earlier called the Red State
murder problem in 2020
per capita murder rates were 40 percent
higher in States Trump won than in
States Biden one 40 percent higher if
you look at 2020 at the 10 states with
the highest murder rates eight of them
voted for the Presidential nominee from
the Republican party in every election
this Century so far now I don't want to
do the thing that the right does on so
many different issues whether it's gas
prices or debt and deficit and whatever
and pretend that the entire Crime Story
is just a matter of when Republicans are
in charge it's more dangerous because
that's actually not so clearly the case
and what I mean by that is crime is
multi-dimensional and very complicated
crime can be influenced by many
different factors it often also
fluctuates from year to year when you
look at crime you have to look at
poverty
inequality which we know as a big impact
on crime education levels per capita
income the relationship between
political affiliation and crime rates is
one Element and it's not straightforward
but the reason I bring all of this up to
you is that the right wing Narrative of
dangerous Democratic cities or states or
whatever it's absolutely and completely
bogus now I do want to give you one
other
uh I don't even know what this is I I
want to advise you of one other way in
which this conversation is often
mishandled by many there's a game that
can be played which is you can say oh
you know what red states are far more
dangerous on average than blue States oh
okay so then Republicans will come in
and say no no no no no but the problem
is even within the red States most of
the violence is in the blue cities but
then you can come back and say well hold
on a second
just the fact that the violence is in
the cities doesn't really mean it's
because of Democrats because much of
this policy is set at the state level
and the state legislature and the state
senate are Republican and then you can
go back and say well but within the
cities the crime is mostly within the
districts that are from democratic City
councilors okay I think you get the
point that this can be sliced and diced
a whole bunch of different ways so my
message here isn't to say it is because
of Republicans necessarily in every case
that violent crime and homicide and all
these things are higher the point is the
right-wing story about crime in Democrat
cities so-called is completely and
totally wrong but what this is all about
is interference running interference for
Trump and his indictment when Trump was
arrested and indicted a week and a half
ago the strategy was very clear what can
Republicans in the house do to help
Donald Trump and one of the things Jim
Jordan has chosen to do is to have these
absurd hearings in New York City rather
than in Washington DC where they should
be in order to try to distract I don't
think it'll work we'll be watching them
closely and we'll have clips for you
later this week it's April which means
Earth month is here this is the time to
consider the products you buy and the
impact they have on our planet so if
you're still using conventional toilet
paper in your home there's no better
time to switch to Reels 100 percent
bamboo toilet paper 30 million trees are
destroyed every year for toilet paper in
the U.S alone real paper makes toilet
paper from 100 bamboo stocks which grow
forever no cutting down trees so when
you use real it doesn't feel like you're
sacrificing anything to help the Earth
real paper is soft and fluffy the way
you're used to it's always shipped free
to my door in plastic free packaging I
can schedule it on a subscription if I
want and real is partnered with one tree
planted and with every box of real paper
you buy they fund reforestation efforts
across the country make a positive
change this Earth month go to
realpaper.com Pacman use code Pacman for
30 off and free shipping the link is
down below